[Musique]
m libert vous êtes une des figures
incontestées de la communauté française
en séries si fabienne keller et ils
passent à une vitesse ces journées vous
êtes connus comme les pousses de
l'illustre henri houdebert aller aux
maldives à nouveau former une communauté
on est soudé et si vous avez quelque
chose à ronsard parlerait on fait
rentrer la reine vous êtes encore pour
deux ans à vienne
c'est formidable le très convaincant
folle de joie
comment fait-on pour gérer tant de
bonheur on arrive à garder les pieds sur
terre
vous avez le passé henri iii qu'il est
allé voir les enfants
[Musique]
c'est encore debout bah oui comme tu
vois pas répartie se sent très loin moi
fait des trucs chacun de notre côté
je te crois de toi
c'est sûr qu'elle se doute pas d'un truc
ta femme
tous les parents d'élèves ont reçu un
mail de la maîtresse de malo qui ne nous
était pas du tout destiné
ça veut dire qu'elle entretient une
liaison avec un papa de l'école on des
qui sera l'heureux élu
tu sais ma nous jamais on se sépare avec
son but du plan non non pas du tout
[Musique]
exact intéressant fait le prestige les
apparences